how do you live a big life and remain
grounded and connected
that's oh that's a deep good very good
question because it's not just for
people who are living the stereotypic
big life
um because no matter how far we've gone
I still see myself the way you see
yourself I'm Michelle do Robinson what
you know nobody who knew who we were
until we were in our 40s I mean who is
Barack Obama you know we've spent the
majority of Our Lives living as a lovely
loving married couple on the south side
of Chicago we had great jobs we got
engaged in service we had these two
little girls
and then my husband decided to run for
president
and I was like what is wrong with you we
have a nice life here why are you gonna
snatch it from us
um so what I say about the White House
the White House doesn't change you who
you are it reveals who you are and if
you were raised to be grounded and
humble
you you carry you practice that that is
who you are
um and so for me I was raised on the
south side of Chicago by Marion Frazier
Robinson and they taught us to respect
people to work hard to treat each other
as we would want to be treated and you
speak about it so incredibly in the book
I feel like I know your mom and dad from
reading the book they are amazing
regular people have you ever been
intimidated to cross a room to go over
to someone absolutely who was that I I
talk about this in the chapter where I
talk about what it feels like to be and
only or first yes right and there are a
lot of people who were in that position
sometimes we think about it in terms of
race in terms of gender but you know if
your first generation college student
and you are nobody in your family has
ever gone to college you will be
intimidated by sitting in a college
classroom or to raise your hand to ask a
question because you're a first or and
only we are all traversing those things
and like I said I never try to allow
those moments to stop me from moving
forward
um you have to kind of push past your
comfort zone and it takes practice right
I wasn't always confident walking across
the room but what I had were parents who
told me not to let my fear guide me
so they continue they they started
pushing me early out of the nest to try
new things walking to school by yourself
it's the basic things that a parent can
allow their child to do that starts
building confidence so I tell the story
about me being in kindergarten and my
mother we lived in around the the corner
from our school on Euclid Avenue I went
to the neighborhood public school and my
mother decided okay here's an alarm
clock it's time for you to wake yourself
up and you can walk around the corner to
school
I was like a lady are you crazy I am
five years old I didn't say that but
that's what was going through my little
mind
um but I did it and the lesson that I
learned from her is that she had to
overcome her fear of letting me go
and a lot of times as parents we hold on
tight for too long we don't want our
kids to experience the fear that anxiety
but the one thing that I say is that if
you don't let your kids folk practice
Their Fear they never learn how
competent they can be so that walk to
kindergarten was the first of many uh
exercises you know leaving the south
side of Chicago and going to an Ivy
League school where my college counselor
told me I wasn't Princeton material so
going to that school was overcoming a
set of hurdles of being a first and then
being on an Ivy League campus where
you're one of a handful of black
students where you're treated as sort of
like a novelty so
the practice of CR the act of crossing
the room is a practice and I have been
practicing it my whole life so when it
was time for me to walk across that
stage with my husband to stand by him as
he took the oath of office I was
practiced in walking across hard rooms
get close girl
okay so I need to cross the room
you have to cross the room especially if
it's me okay do it
we like to be a little uh Goofy and
silly around here will you play a game
with me yes
yes I've heard I have some foods that
literally I would rather I'd rather eat
a shoe or lick a pole or do anything
than put in my mouth is it true you have
that too oh yeah what is yours beets
okay so what does this game have to do
with Beats
there's some beets over there and we
could play a game okay to try and win
really selling it not putting it in our
mouth it's called who knew don't spew
okay
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
[Music]
foreign